in Deutschland gelten 520 Tierarten und
512 Pflanzen und Pilze bereits
ausgestorben nun wurde in die neue
bedrohte Art entdeckt der waschechte
Bayern mit der wissenschaftlichen
Bezeichnung
barbarinöses
Verbreitungsgebiet erstreckt sich über
Oberbayern und Niederbayern und naja mit
ein bisschen Duden Willen auch über die
Oberpfalz und irgendwie heute auch
über Franken und wenn wir bis zum
Äußersten gehen würde dann in ganz
normal auch noch ja über Teile von
Schwaben aber jetzt ist der Bayer vom
Aussterben bedroht die Gründe hierfür
sind vielfältig so ist zum Beispiel
durch eine Veränderung der Umwelt das
natürliche Fortpflanzungsverhalten des
Bayern massiv beeinträchtigt
[Musik]
nicht nur die Zivilisation erweist sich
als Störfaktor bei der bayerischen
Fortpflanzung nein auch die Konkurrenz
durch eingeschleppte Arten unter diesen
eingeschleppten Arten ist eine besonders
gefährlich der Adonis muskulöses und so
häufen sich im freien Feld die
Beobachtungen dass der barbarenzis
hollerraddoliöses während der Balzzeit
im farbenprächtigen Adonis muskulöses im
direkten Wettbewerb meist unterliegen
ist
aber nicht nur die Fortpflanzung stellt
mittlerweile für den Bayern ein
Problemfeld da auch im Bereich der
Nahrungssuche ist eine existenzmassiv
bedroht
bedingt durch negative Umwelteinflüsse
werden die typischen Nahrungsquellen für
den traditionellen Fleisch und vor allem
viel fressenden Bayern immer knapper
bitteschön
[Musik]
diese dramatische Situation hat uns auf
dem Plan gerufen den bayerischen
bayern-schutzbund Bayern
unterstützen auch Sie uns langes zur
jawohl damit mir Bayern morgen animiert
an der bayerische bayern-schutzbund
Bayern
[Applaus]
[Musik]